if you call me nip with a heart P I lose
it you can call me that Michael you know
when I was on my coaches have a little
nippy yeah bubbly here ya know when I
was a little too a fire remember one
night I was on the Alma fire 30 2005
mm-hmm well obviously it's a reality TV
show so we know what it is yeah but
listen I'm breaking it down and Farah
maybe they'll think I mean what are they
called the followers sleepers what the
sleep maybe the sleepers don't know mr.
[ __ ] little net so listen so you go
to bed at night you know you sleep like
whether or not you're on a reality TV
show you still need to sleep you got to
sleep unless you can't sleep you start
talking running with a camera straight
away you know so I'm like I'm letting
bed and I can't sleep it on my Kendall
Grove God sleep
I'm we just chatting away next minute
boom Oh lights on camera crew in filming
is about what the [ __ ] man get the [ __ ]
out they're like no no I'm sorry you're
talking we've got to film it am i [ __ ]
off I said we trying to get to sleep
we're just having a little a little chat
you know get the [ __ ] out and the good
walk I'll say you cheeky bastard and
anyway till you walk out next day
[ __ ] the head producers like yo Mike
We Need to Talk
all right what's up says you can't use
racial terms to our cameraman what and
what what the [ __ ] are you talking about
they said you called him a [ __ ]
bastard I'm like no
he was an Asian cheeky bastard a cheeky
cheeky Oh was the cameraman Asian is yes
oh yeah just like you yeah yeah it was
me Michael
it was my previous job Oh Terri oh wow
so you said cheeky bastard and then the
that means he complained he complained
right he was I'm gonna show him okay you
call me [ __ ] haha that's what he said
and the producers like you [ __ ]
little [ __ ] get the [ __ ] out you fired
so did nothing happen right he was
resolved no I said shut the [ __ ] up I
said cheeky bastard yeah yeah because we
don't say that in the mirror no you
don't say what does it mean chi-chi's
the best word ever it can mean it could
mean so many things that you can have a
cheeky like you hunt I'm having a cheeky
camera monster here a cheeky podcast all
right someone's being that rude and a
little forthcoming a little bi you know
like helping themselves are you cheeky
bastard their mind has a lot of
different meanings let me see I can see
with my own merit yeah yeah come on ask
me for some candy hey can I get some of
those no you cheeky bastard are you all
cheeky nothing ggggg yeah I like it a
lot of me you hey why'd you laugh at
that torch
why he left so [ __ ] hard at me saying
cheeky bro excuse me why the [ __ ] did
you do that does
your face got all red yeah left right in
my [ __ ] face bro all right but watch
it did
[Music]